SEAN HANNITY, SPEAKING OF CHEER,
IS A NEW YORK TONIGHT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TUCKER.
I THINK WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
GOOD SHOW, TUCKER.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THE FULL HOUR
TO GET ALL OF US IN.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK THIS DOWN.
WILL GIVE YOU ALL THE NEWS AND
INFORMATION THE MOB WILL NEVER
GIVE YOU.
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WE'LL START WITH A SUMMARY.
THE PSYCHOTICS, AND TO TRUMP
HYSTERIA, IT IS NOW COMPLETELY
OVERTAKEN THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS DANGEROUS
TO THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS GROSSLY POLITICAL.
IT WILL FOREVER ALTER HOW ANY
PRESIDENT IN THE FUTURE, IN HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, WILL BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE FREELY WITH OTHER
WORLD LEADERS.
THE WORLD IS LESS SAFE AND
SECURE TONIGHT AS A RESULT OF
YET THE LATEST PARTISAN
WITCH HUNT.
WE'LL BREAK IT ALL DOWN.
WHAT WE HAVE, THOUGH, AT THE
ROOT OF ALL THIS IS AN
IRRATIONAL HATRED.
TRUMP RAGE.
IT IS ALL THIS PARTY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NOW STANDS FOR
TODAY.
I WILL PREDICT TONIGHT, THEY
HAVE DONE DONALD TRUMP A HUGE
FAVOR.
IT WILL ALL BACKFIRE AND BLOW UP
RIGHT IN THEIR FACE.
SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI WAS FORCED
TO CAVE TO A RADICAL BASE THAT
ANNOUNCED AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
THAT WANTS TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
UKRAINE.
COLLUSION.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS, BECAUSE
THERE ARE NONE.
THIS HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
THE LEFT'S UNYIELDING,
UNHEALTHY, WHAT IS AN
OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE HATRED OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY CAN'T ACCEPT THAT HE WON.
THAT WAS NOVEMBER 2016.
THEY ARE STILL THERE.
AND I THINK THEY EVEN DOUBT THEY
CAN BEAT HIM AT THE BALLOT BOX,
WHICH IS WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO THIS NOW.
HE OCCUPIES EVERY SINGLE
CONSCIOUS THOUGHT IN THEIR
MINDS.
IT'S LIKE THE MOMENT THEY MAKE
UP IS THE MOMENT THEY FALL
ASLEEP.
DONALD TRUMP LIVES IN THE HEADS
OF THESE PSYCHOTIC DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB.
HE KIND OF LIVES THERE RENT FREE
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY SECOND OF
EVERY DAY.
IT IS A SICKNESS, BUT NOW IT'S
OFFICIALLY HURTING THE COUNTRY
AS IT RULES THEIR LIVES.
SO, WHAT ARE THE GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT?
ACCORDING TO PELOSI TODAY, IT'S
ALL ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PHONE CALL WITH HIS UKRAINIAN
COUNTERPART.
KEEP IN MIND, TRUMP ORDERED THE
TRANSCRIPT BEFORE HER
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE RELEASED.
THAT WILL HAPPEN TOMORROW.
I HAVE NUMEROUS SOURCES TELLING
ME TONIGHT THAT THE ONLY THING
THE PRESIDENT DISCUSSED WITH THE
NEW PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, WELL,
WAS WHAT HE RAN ON, WHICH WAS
ENDING CORRUPTION, WHICH THE NEW
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT PLEDGED TO
DO.
BY THE WAY, DOES ANYONE CARE AT
ALL THAT OUR PRESIDENT IS BEING
SPIED ON AGAIN?
WILL GET IN IT    COME BACK INTO
WILL GET IN IT    COME BACK INTI
WILL GET IN IT    COME BACK INTT
LATER TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT'S CONVERSATIONS
WITH PRIME MINISTER'S AND
PRESIDENTS.
WHAT FOREIGN LEADER WILL EVER
AGAIN BE WILLING TO FREELY TALK
TO A U.S. PRESIDENT?
WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A
MOMENT.
BUT ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE CALL, THAT WILL BE RELEASED
BY THE END OF THE WEEK.
BUT THE RADICAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS, THEY JUST COULDN'T
WAIT ANOTHER SECOND.
THEY DON'T CARE THAT THEY
HAVEN'T SEEN THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE CALL.
THEY DON'T CARE THAT THE
SO-CALLED "WHISTLE-BLOWER" WAS
NEVER A WHISTLE-BLOWER OR THAT
THEY HAD NO DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT HAPPENS ON THAT CALL.
THEY DON'T CARE THAT UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS, THAT'S RIGHT, AND
OTHERS THAT ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED ON THE CALL, HAVE ALL
BEEN A MENTALLY DENIED THE
ACCUSATIONS OF ANY QUID PRO QUO.
MULTIPLE SOURCES CONFIRMING TO
ME AGAIN TONIGHT THAT THERE IS
NO QUID PRO QUO.
ACCORDING TO NANCY, IT DOESN'T
EVEN NEED TO BE A QUID PRO QUO
IN ORDER TO IMPEACH.
WATCH THIS INSANITY UNFOLDING.
>> Pelosi: IN TERMS OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS ONE IS THE MOST
UNDERSTANDABLE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THIS.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT FOR A
QUID PRO QUO IN THE
CONVERSATION.
IF THE PRESIDENT BRINGS UP THAT
HE WANTS THEM TO INVESTIGATE
SOMETHING, THAT'S OF HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THAT IS SELF-EVIDENT THAT IS NOT
RIGHT.
>> Sean: THE DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
OH, YOU ONLY CARE IF IT'S
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TELL HIM THAT VLADIMIR WILL HAVE
MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
WE'LL JUST SKIP THEM HUNDRED 50
BUCKS.
ALL RIGHT NANCY NANCY.
HOLD YOUR VOTE.
IF YOU'RE SO WORRIED, LET'S DO
THIS.
LET'S SEE HOW FAR THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS WILLING TO
TAKE THIS POLITICAL STUNT.
I SAY TO THE SPEAKER, WELL, IN
NAME ONLY, OR TO THE CALL.
I WANT EVERY ONE OF YOUR
DEMOCRATS ON THE RECORD.
I DARE YOU TO DO IT.
NOW, I'M SURE THE REAL SPEAKER,
THAT WOULD BE
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, WILL
DEMAND IT.
I ALSO PREDICT YOU ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO BUCKLE, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW YOUR JOB'S ON THE LINE, AND
YOU ARE NOT IN CONTROL OF YOUR
CAUCUS AT ALL.
SO LET'S GET THIS ON THE RECORD.
LET'S SEE DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS,
YOU KNOW, ONES FROM OH, LOOK
RIGHT THERE, BOTH ALL DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKERS THAT WON DISTRICTS
THAT DONALD TRUMP WON.
LET'S GET THEM ON THE RECORD.
DO THEY HAVE THE COURAGE TO DO
THAT CUSTOMER WILL THEY SUPPORT
IMPEACHMENT OVER NOTHING?
WILL THEY TRASH THE WILL OF
THEIR OWN CONSTITUENTS?
WILL THEY CONTINUE TO WASTE
TIME, TAXPAYER MONEY OVER
DERANGED POLITICAL FOLLY THAT
WILL GO NOWHERE IN THE U.S.
SENATE, AND BY THE WAY,
CONGRESSMAN, GOLDEN CONGRESSMAN
MALONEY, CONGRESSMAN SUZY LEE
AND ALL THE REST OF THEM THERE,
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
31 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS MUST NOW
COME OUT OF HIDING.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHERE YOU STAND
ON YOUR LEADER OF YOUR PARTY.
DO YOU ANSWER TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR ARE YOU JOINING
THE SQUAD OF RADICAL SOCIALIST
THAT WANT TO BAN COWS AND PLANES
AND GET RID OF THE LIFEBLOOD OF
OUR ECONOMY, OIL AND GAS, AND
TAX AMERICA INTO A BOLIVIA AND
JUST GROW GREATEST WEALTH
CREATING SYSTEM.
BY THE WAY, DO YOU WANT THAT AS
MUCH AS YOU WANT TO DESTROY
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
FRANKLY.
I HAVE NO FAITH THAT YOU WILL
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION.
AFTER ALL, YOUR SO-CALLED
LEADER, NANCY PELOSI, IS NOW
TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
CONTROLLED BY A COUPLE OF
FRESHMEN LAWMAKERS IN CONGRESS.
THE CHAIR WOMAN WHO DOESN'T KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CRIMEA
AND KOREA.
THIS IS THE LEADER OF THE
SOCIALIST PARTY.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE FREE.
FOR THREE LONG YEARS, THEY HAVE
PUT THIS COUNTRY THROUGH HELL
AND THEY HAVEN'T LIFTED A SINGLE
FINGER, NOTHING TO MAKE THIS
COUNTRY A MORE SECURE COUNTRY, A
BETTER PLACE WITH MORE JOBS,
MORE OPPORTUNITY, MORE ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
ONE OF THEIR PLANS TO BOAST
AMERICAN INDUSTRY AND CREATE
JOBS?
WHERE OTHER PLANS TO KEEP
AMERICA SAFE AND SECURE?
WHERE ARE THEIR PLANS TO SOLVE
THE MURDER CRISIS IN AMERICA'S
BIGGEST CITIES LIKES WOW LIKE
CHICAGO AND ALL THE OTHER CITIES
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING HORRIBLE
SCHOOLS?
THE ANSWER IS NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
THAT IS WHAT TODAY IS ABOUT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOW SPENT THREE
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        H
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        P
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        R
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        E
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        T
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        L
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        N
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        G
YEARS HYPER VENTILATING        .
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA, STORMY,
STORMY, STORMY, IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
UKRAINE, UKRAINE.
HOW DOES ANY OF THIS RAGE HELP
ANY AMERICAN?
THREE LONG YEARS YOU HAVE
DRAGGED THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
PRESIDENT A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT THROUGH THE MUD, AND
WE ARE ABOUT TO SEE ALL OF THE
CORRUPT DEALINGS AND HANDLE
LIENS OF OH, INTELLIGENCE, AND
ALL THE LYING AND ALL THE
CONSPIRACY IS BY THE
MEDIA MOB IN THIS COUNTRY.
NO WORLD LEADER WILL EVER WANT
TO HAVE AN HONEST PHONE
CONVERSATION WITH ANY PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IS THAT GOOD FOR OUR SAFETY AND
SECURITY?
I WOULD THINK IT'S A GOOD THING
THAT WE HAVE ENUMERATED POWERS
IN THE CONSTITUTION AND WE HAVE,
YES, ONE COMMANDER AND CHIEF.
I CAN THINK OF A SINGLE TIME IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY BEFORE DONALD TRUMP,
WHERE A PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALLS
WITH OTHER WORLD LEADERS WERE
REPEATEDLY HACKED INTO AND
LEAKED TO THE PUBLIC.
NOW, IT HAPPENS LEFT AND RIGHT.
WHO LEAKED THE CONTENTS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CALL WITH THE
AUSTRALIAN PRIME MINISTER?
WHO LEAKED WHISTLE-BLOWER, WELL,
IT'S NOT A WHISTLE-BLOWER, CALL
WITH THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT?
EVERYONE ON THE PHONE WITH THE
U.S. PRESIDENT IS PROBABLY
SAYING, "OH, IT'S PROBABLY GOING
TO BE LEAKED TO ONE DAY."
THAT IS NOT GOING TO ADVANCE
PEACE IN THE WORLD.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO CARE
ABOUT IS THEIR INSATIABLE URGE
AND COMPULSION TO IMPEACH TRUMP.
THAT IS WHY TONIGHT, THE REAL
LEADER OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS VERY PLEASED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THAT WE ALL, MANY OF
US, ESPECIALLY FROM DISTRICTS
THERE EXPERIENCING, HAVE BEEN.
I THINK THAT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
RHONDA WHISTLE-BLOWER
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TONIGHT,
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THAT SANCTITY,
YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY, PRESIDENT TRUMP CREATED
JOBS OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS.
WE NOW HAVE THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969.
OH, RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS,
THE MOB WILL NEVER TELL YOU
THIS, THE MEDIA, WE ARE NOW A
NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY AND ARE
COMPLETELY ENERGY INDEPENDENT,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, IT'S TIME TO
SEND WASHINGTON A MESSAGE.
THAT MEANS THEY ARE LESS
STRATEGICALLY GEOPOLITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAN THEY'VE EVER BEEN
TO THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
WE DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO GET
INVOLVED IN ENTANGLEMENTS THAT
WE OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE IN THE
PAST.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO TELL YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES THAT YOU DON'T
PAY THEM TO SPEND EVERY SECOND
OF EVERY DAY, EVERY YEAR AFTER
YEAR, HOUR AFTER HOUR TRYING TO
DESTROY A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT ELECTIONS ARE FOR.
YOU CAN TELL THEM YOU ARE DONE
WITH THIS.
YOU ARE DONE WITH THE NEVER
ENDING WITCH HUNTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS DULY ELECTED
BY WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IN
SPITE OF EFFORTS TO OH, LET'S
SEE, SPY ON THEM AND USE RUSSIAN
LIES FROM THE GET-GO.
THAT WOULD BE HILLARY'S DIRTY
DOSSIER THAT SAVED HER FROM
GOING TO JAIL, THAT WOULD BE THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
BY THE WAY, I WOULDN'T TRY IT AT
HOME, WHAT'S HILLARY DID, IF YOU
HAVE EMAILS THAT ARE SUBPOENAED.
YOU WILL BE CHARGED WITH
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
SOMETHING THEY PROTECTED HER
FROM.
IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS NOW.
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO GET OVER.
THEY LOST.
TRY AND BEAT DONALD TRUMP AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
I DON'T THINK YOU BELIEVE YOU
CAN.
BY THE WAY, THAT WON'T HAPPEN IF
THEY NOMINATE
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE
30330.
THANKS TO THE LEFT'S UKRAINE
HISTORY.
THEY HAVE NOW DONE AMERICA A
FAVOR, BECAUSE NOW, JOE BIDEN IS